- [Interviewer] So Scott, Scott.
Oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Scott] I'm originally from Maine.
It's where I wished I would have been
able to grow up.
My father was an air force
so we traveled overseas
mostly when I was a kid.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of childhood did you have?
- It was great until my
dad had to leave to Korea.
He was in the air force,
you know, career.
And my mom divorced him
in the Midwest and I was not having that.
You know.
I mean, especially living
overseas, like the Philippines.
I like adventure and
Nebraska was not adventurous.
So I left, I got in trouble
when I was 12 and just left
but it was more or less,
my mom wanted me to go.
It wasn't like I was ended up
on the streets because
of choice, but because of
rejection
- [Interviewer] What kind of
trouble are you getting into?
- Really nothing illegal.
I just wasn't going to school.
I couldn't read or write
at the time would do math
or any of that stuff.
It was nothing.
The only thing that I
could had any contact
with were animals.
And that was strange to my family.
So;
well with my mother and brother, my sister
who was doing good there from
another dad, which makes them
you know, fortunate because
the dad, I have had problems
and It carried onto me
and it bothered me a lot.
And I wanted to hide that
and running away was my way
of
hiding
what I really am,
you know?
And it hurt, you know, I
didn't want people to know.
I couldn't learn.
And,
but
I was 12.
That was in seventy six.
- [Interviewer] You ran away at 12.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So how
far did you get in school?
- I didn't have a grade,
I was in special ed.
Yeah, I literally couldn't read
or write until I was 17, at least.
And it was hitchhiking
to different cities and States
and seeing this, you know.
Welcome to the state of
California that it just caught.
And,
but when you go that far
and then finally learn, it's
already too late, you know
You're going to end up
being a lifer like this.
- [Interviewer] You were
on the street for how long?
- 76
to
2006.
So that's quite a long time, I think.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And I started getting little rooms but.
15 by 15
rooms
with just a,
you know, a bathroom
that's in the hallway.
And,
but I was too,
I'm like, you know
if I'm going to pay to live
in a room because see at first
I wasn't on SSI and I should have been
on SSI for years before
I ever got onto it.
But
I just,
just didn't care about anything.
And,
I don't know where you
want to go with this
but I ended up in LA, I was 14.
That was in 78.
And,
being that you do remember.
I don't talk too much about it
but I've had enough of people
who look like they're normal.
And I was at this place
called Oki Dogs where
there was punk rockers and everything.
And I didn't really know
what, what was going on.
And then one Friday night,
I got picked up by the LA freeway killer.
And that happened to be a
really bad experience that night
on and I was on LSD
and
wherever I jumped out of the car
it was in someplace called Rosemead.
And to this day, I don't
know where that is, but
or how far it was from
Oki Dogs in Hollywood.
But I jumped out of the car,
ran into a, there was a church
and there was a, in an alley.
And I jumped down in
the window that was like
in the basement, but it
was like a little spot.
And I just stayed there until daylight.
And some girls, some girl was
going to school and saw me
and I was bloody and everything.
And she gave me money.
And I said, where are you from?
I said from Hollywood,
you know, and I went back
to Hollywood and I, that
very day I got a Mohawk
and I wanted to look like the
most scariest evilest thing
because the only people
that seemed like it was cool
to me were people that looked
like they weren't cool.
You know, that was, that's
a different era, you know
than what we see today.
Now, people who look like they ain't cool.
Aren't cool,
but that's my own opinion.
But
- [Interviewer] So the dad
that raised you was your?
- My stepdad,
- [Interviewer] Your stepdad.
- And who I really admire
and respect.
- [Interviewer] But your,
your, your actual father.
- No, he, I never knew him.
- [Interviewer] You don't
know anything of him?
- I knew that he had the
same learning problems, same
like I have a problem
with my back and it's
all pretty much genetic.
And I didn't like my posture.
It made me feel like I
couldn't hit on girls.
So I really, really was
the only friends that I had
were basically pets, you
know, rats, particularly
I like rats because they
were the farthest thing
that any human being really cared about.
But I saw myself in rats.
- [Interviewer] Is that the
animal that you relate to?
Yeah. I still have them to this very day,
but
years later
and like in 88,
87, when they
they had this big homeless
thing about tent city and SF
and every news camera people
in the world was there filming.
And I was like, you know
the way I stand out now is
the way I stood out then.
And they were running to me
and it kind of gave me
a little self-esteem
about who I am being homeless.
You know,
I would hitchhike
I didn't really go to big
cities because I was scared.
And, but I didn't know how
to survive really well either.
I wouldn't carry a
sleeping bag or a blanket
because I didn't want people
to know I was homeless
and
it was really
screwed up,
you know
and
now that
I am not
off the street,
but
and see the effect is
still there, you know?
And,
and I try real hard to
turn it off, you know
and I've been learning a little bit
you know, I'm,
self-taught
I built a computer, I wrote a book.
I'm trying to do positive
things, but there's other things
in my life that's
really,
it's like a,
it's like,
I'm on hold.
You know, just like this
thing that's going on
right now with, with
everything being stopped
in the city
and around the country, that's
the way I feel every day.
Anyways, I feel like I'm in a prison.
As a matter of fact, I've
been to prison and I was freer
on the inside than I have
ever been on the outside.
And I'm
and I'm
I'm in pretty solid though.
I've never done anything that I
for anything that I wouldn't want to do
just so I could get something,
you know.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of your life?
- Yes.
I smoke crystal,
not a lot,
but at least
if you were to say, if
you're smoking a cigarette
and you take four or five
hits every day off a cigarette
and then put it out, that's
about where I'm at now.
It used to be, I was.
I started doing
intravenous drugs in 84
when I came up here from LA
because in LA the Olympics was going on.
The cops was not cool.
And I came up here and the
scene was really jumping off
and
I got introduced to a shooting speed.
I was 20 years old and
I never thought
that I used to tell myself that
I would never going to stay
in this city more than a year
because I would never leave after that.
And that I'd never
stay up more than two days.
And I wouldn't do it more than
twice a week
but it ended up being real quick
like doing it every day, except for two
for months
And then I, and then
I eventually did leave
and I didn't go through any
culture shock until after 2000.
I had already been here so many years
that wherever I went after here,
the world is just so big.
And you know, this city,
you can get anything
and do anything within
a three block radius.
And
I feel like this is my turf.
There isn't a person
in the city that cannot say
they don't know the red man.
That's what they call
me, red man, you know?
And,
and I
enjoy that
but I also want to
also want to get it together.
I don't know what that world is like.
I mean, I know a lot of good
people, musicians from LA.
You know Anaheim, you know,
Oxnard area,
Ventura and all of that.
And, you know, they
support me, but you know
I'm just a different kind of person
tired of feeling that way, you know
- [Interviewer] Did you
always feel like an outcast?
- Yeah. I mean,
a matter of fact, I even felt like as far
as hardcore goes like
a biker or punk rocker,
to me it seems like none
of them has me out beat
but you know,
when you're 56,
you do think a lot.
And I do think a lot
and I don't discredit
how smart I really am.
I would learn a different way, you know
but it's kinda sucks
that the way I learned
it screws me up,
you know,
as far as being able to use it,
unless I get lucky, you know
- [Interviewer] What do
you do for money now?
How do you support yourself?
- Well, I get social security and
my rent, I got
there's a thing called section
eight that I finally got
after many of years.
And
that makes my rent down
to like 200 a month.
And one thing I used to
dream about is I always
wanted a room with a view
of the skyline because
I love this city.
And, and I actually got
a view, of the skyline
with a full kitchen, full shower bedroom.
And, but yet it's still hard to,
there's a lot
of things that they didn't
to live normal is very
it's still a learning
process after two years.
I'm still having problems,
you know, realizing
that you gotta do your dishes,
you gotta mop your floor
and
you know.
But
- [Interviewer] Do you
describe yourself as happy?
- No
No.
I'm,
I'm actually
very very
I even been labeled as super depressed
and
no
they
call me dual diagnosis depression
but the level that I'm
on is a very low level
with
on top of
over excessive
thinking,
you know
and also
I got PTSD
because of,
you know, I don't care, just
you know, and understand
what this video is about.
But I used to have a lot of rats over
over a couple 100
in my apartment.
And,
and that was the only
thing that made me happy.
But because of that,
I got in trouble with the city
and
they forced me to kill a lot of them.
And I go through a lot of post depression
over that, because they're,
they're a wonderful animal.
They're, they're misunderstood.
And that's the way I feel about myself.
You know, one time I was in an elevator
in a building when I was still homeless
wearing I had a punk rock jacket then too,
with studs and spike
but it was a mother and her child.
And for some reason the lady
had the balls to just say,
excuse me.
I don't mean to disrespect
you, but have you
has anybody ever told you, said to you
that you look like you
scare all women and children
and that kind of never really
left my, I never forgot that
but what I really wanted
to tell the lady was
and I think I did.
I told her, I says, no
if you really look,
you'll see, you'll see me.
You see, you see
the,
you know,
I think pretty much did
if you were going to do art, then
then I try to make everything into art.
Even the way I look, you know
I'm sure that's the way anybody does
whether it just be wearing a suit
and
not even like to do that
if I ever had the money, but
man, you'd have to be a lot
of money because I
won't wear no cheap shit
(person laughing)
but
I haven't lost my mind
or gone off the wall.
And I love the police.
I have, I
I can look
anybody in the eye,
you know,
you know
and not have any and any trip
and talking to you now.
Whereas when I was a kid,
I'm okay with where I'm at and
what I'm at, but then I can
I'm not okay because I do smoke.
And I do think, you know
I'm not
fulfilling the dream
that I can make
best of
you know, with what I got now.
And I never,
57,
56 years
of not
at least trying, makes me feel
like did I'm going to go
to my grave the way I am.
And that just kills me so bad.
It really does, man.
I feel like I need to hit a lottery
or something that they come
up or, you know, do something.
But you know, but you know, then again
I realized I had money
in my pocket every year
I got over a 100 dollars
in my pocket now that I just don't use.
So I couldn't imagine myself
having a million dollars
and it'd been any different
because of my situation.
You know
- [Interviewer] what's your biggest fear?
- My biggest fear is a
this might trip you out.
And It is my biggest
fear and that is going
to my grave
without having
Jesus in my life.
If you could understand
that for whatever reason
that's where I'm at.
And right now I do not
feel like I'm there.
I do not feel
like I
am an image
that is mirrored from my creator.
And that really bothers me bad.
You know, I destroyed the
temple, my body, you know
and
now
it's just,
you know,
I'm not living, you know
a life that's just
you know, day to day, you know
just live like, you know,
you're supposed to, you know
regardless if I'm poor or not,
you know, I'm just, you know
I'm still using sometimes I drink,
but it only lasts for about
a couple of weeks,
every three months
because I just whatever,
but I'm never broke.
And for some reason, after
being here so many years
there's not a person who
doesn't know me, which is
can be good, but then the bad thing
about it is I never have to buy anything.
And that, that kinda is not good
for me if I might really
want to try to be free.
And like I said
the only time I've ever been
free was when I was in prison.
That's because everything
that I was I had to do
in prison
was basically,
you know,
forced upon, you know
can't do drugs in that place when we could
but I wasn't trying to,
and
I miss being happy.
Like I wasn't when I was in
prison, but then I miss a lot
of other things too, but mostly my
I'm not happy.
I got a brother and sister
that are millionaires
and to ask for a
CPU for my computer because
my CPU just burnt out.
And I took it out because I had a radiator
in my computer that was 23
years old from an old Alienware
and the thing just overheated my CPU.
And I can't even get three
or 400 bucks for a new
I seven processor,
you know
and that hurts, you know
especially when I got
a sister that's got 11
muscle cars
of her choice, you know, and you know
my brother has got an
Olympic swimming pool.
I can't get a simple
processor for my computer.
That can help me keep
myself busy, you know
and that's, that kind of bothers me
and also
can be a little
reason why I
continue to mess up and use, you know,
but
I'm still really pretty solid people.
You know, that's rare in this city
and in LA
(Person laughing)
- [Interviewer] Do, do you
feel like you were ever loved?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like you were ever loved
as a child or
- Never.
The only thing
that
That I
I know is that I had a
stepdad that I looked
up to look forward to him
coming home, looked forward
to going to a new country or something,
you know
that was fun, you know, but
that
was up until I was 11
and then he had to go
to Korea and then my mom
divorced him in between that.
And I didn't want the divorce,
but I,
but who knows
I still might have
ended up on the streets.
I don't know.
I don't know what would have happened
but I know that my real father,
when I found out that some
of my learning and
my back,
you know, being screwed up
you know, can be, which I know for fact
is because of
finding out who my real
brother and my real sister is.
I mean, the brother and sister I have now
is from my stepdad or my half-brother
and sister from my mom,
but I have another dad.
I didn't know that some may when he died.
But when I found out that some
of these problems I have can be genetic.
I became murderous because
even when I was a kid
even though I wasn't able to learn
education.
I still knew something was wrong.
And I knew that I was cursed.
It was like a curse because how
could somebody be like that?
And not just say, well change.
And
you know,
I couldn't do it.
And
now that when I think I can,
it kinda like
seems like it's too late, too
late to ever have children.
Too late to
I don't know
I just hope it ain't too late to
to make peace with my creator.
That's the only important
thing, because there's nothing
in this world
that,
that I take pleasure in nothing anymore.
And
I mean my friends and
everything, all of that.
But then again, you know,
you know it's just the way it is
you know,
but,
and funny thing is, is everywhere
I learned how to read and
write every time I write
or text or anything on Facebook,
whether it be my brother
and sister who did learn
how to read and write
I write something that really makes sense
and can be a little long.
And they just say,
well, the weather's hot.
Everybody's fine.
I hope you're doing good.
Love you.
And if I would have known
that that's all reading
and writing was all about
then I probably would have
learned when I was in jail
because that's sure now what I call
you know,
you know, whatever
- [Interviewer] Communication.
- Communication, yeah.
Social skills, that's one
thing I really have a lot of,
- [Interviewer] Yes you do.
- but I do have, I will
say one thing though
about
the way people in the city are,
a lot of homeless people
that have been here just as
long as I have.
And that is, they will never forget me.
They've told me that, I'm one
of the few people that they ever think of.
And one of the few
people they say that are
and solid
a lot of people are not solid
a good to them to themselves
or to their friends.
It's all about cake, cake, cake, you know
and I'm glad I don't have that
on my show, you know, on my jacket.
You know
- [Interviewer] All right, Red man.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- Yeah, and great talking to you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I'm so glad we met.
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Thank you.